[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport spécial fêtes de noël c'est
parti pour le sommaire football pour son
dernier match de l'année trappes n'a pu
faire mieux que match nul 1 but partout
face à la réserve de versailles le
résumé du match dans ce magazine
football c'est l'une des images de cette
fin d'année pour les supporters du paris
saint germain l'ancien attaquant du psg
pedro miguel pauleta est venu en séance
dédicace à montigny le bretonneux
reportage dans ce set 8 sport nous vous
proposerons également de revivre dans
cette émission tous les moments forts
qui ont rythmé la vie sportive revinoise
en 2019 rétrospective à suivre
l'actualité à sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78 on commence tout de suite par
du football dans le championnat de
régionale 2 trappe et l'équipe réserve
de versailles se sont séparés sur un
match nul dans ce derby yvelinois
résultat qui n'arrange aucune des deux
équipes le résumé du match des images de
manon à varaldo un derby noir pour
terminer l'année 2019 trappe recevait
l'équipe réserve de versailles à
l'occasion de la 10e journée de
régionale 2 après une fin de match à
suspense les trappistes arrache
finalement le match nul score final un
but partout
on est rentré en deuxième mi temps avec
un visage un peu plus conquérant et on
avait à coeur de
de ramener au minimum ce point du match
nul c'est un match engagé contre
mais
pour les deux équipes qui jouent le
maintien avec ça va être un combat assez
difficile qui plus est avec un terrain
très compliqué le résultat nul ne
semblait logique après ce résultat trap
est toujours sous la menace d'une
relégation en fin de saison les
trappistes pointe à la 10e place sur 12
équipes engagées
mais l'équipe termine l'année sur une
note positive depuis lors autour sur le
bandit shams et redit trappe reste sur
une série de deux victoires et deux nuls
en quatre matches on va se préparer au
mieux pour encore prendre des points
maximum et s'éloigner de cette zone de
relégation
les moyens on les a les joueurs on les a
pour y arriver maintenant c'est une
lutte de tous les instants c'est un
marathon
donc on verra la fin le championnat de
régionale 2 reprendra le 19 janvier
prochain après une longue trêve trappe
ira défier ozoir dans son côté à
versailles recevra val d'europe
on continue à parler de football et de
l'équipe première de versailles les
versets y connaissent désormais leurs
adversaires pour les 32e de finale de la
coupe de france les joueurs de youssef
chibi pensionnaire de nationale 3 vont
recevoir à domicile granville une équipe
de nationale 2 un tirage abordable pour
le club qui n'a plus connu ce stade de
la compétition depuis dix ans la
rencontre sera programmée le samedi 4
janvier à 13h au stade maubeuge du
handball à présent jouer ce week-end le
dernier match de l'année du côté de
montigny le bretonneux
les féminines ont fait plaisir à leurs
supporters présents en leur offrant une
belle victoire contre les premières du
classement tools carantec le score 35 à
28 cette victoire permet à l'équipe de
terminer troisième du classement avant
noël on écoute le président il nous
dresse son bilan de cette première
partie de saison on aurait pu faire
mieux on aurait pu tout gagné on aurait
pu tout gagner mais on a eu également de
travers on sait on a rencontré l'équipe
d'ici paris de réserve ou en fait
l'équipe pro ne jouait pas et avec des
descentes de joueuse professionnelle qui
nous ont pas fait que du bien c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
on va maintenant parler de rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir
termine par une défaite à domicile
contre saint denis une équipe du haut du
classement le score est sans appel 37 à
24 au classement les plaisirs hu a
terminé à la 10e place et les joueurs
vont devoir lutter pour leur maintien à
l'année à prochaine dans le championnat
de division honneur ce dimanche 15
décembre l'union rugby centre 78 termine
son année par un match nul contre le red
star le score 26 partout au classement
lui verser 60 18 est quatrième avec 26
points engrangés depuis le début de la
saison les saint quentinois sont à 7
points de la deuxième place
coup de projecteur à présent sur un
joueur qui a marqué l'histoire du paris
saint germain selon olé son surnom
l'aigle des açores pedro miguel pauleta
était à ce vendredi en séance dédicace à
montigny le bretonneux et forcément les
fans ont répondu à présent pour ce
cadeau de noël avant l'heure des images
de nicolas landry est arrivée telle une
rock star à montigny le bretonneux pedro
miguel pauleta ancien attaquant du paris
saint-germain de 2003 à 2008 est venue
en séance dédicace dans cette grande
surface
l'occasion pour l'aigle des açores au
109 buts avec le psg de retrouver ses
fans
c'est un plaisir
regardez tout ce fort tard ici à côté de
moi c'est srdjan italienne que ça
continue depuis de 11,2 sommes venus
comme ambassadeur d'une grande marque du
café portugais il a signé des
autographes et pris des photos pendant
plus d'une heure ac 600 supporters
présents certains n'ont pas hésité à
partir plus tôt du travail a patienté
dans la longue file d'attenté super
important quand on voit le joueur
emblématique était pauleta à pouvoir
supporter du psg c'est normal de venir à
cette séance de dédicaces ça fait du
monde pour un jour où 16 heures comme ça
où les gens travaillent
mais je pense que certains se libère
comme en l'occurrence mais bon une fois
dans notre vie après c'est un sacré
souvenir des supporters historiques ont
ressorti des reliques du passé
c'est quand même hein mon idole un
parisien
un vrai buteur j'ai pu déjà rencontré
quand j'étais petit le revend une
deuxième fois plus près c'est génial en
tant qu'abonné depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant vraiment pauleta le
symbole parisien quand même dans les
prochaines semaines pauleta continuera à
sillonner les centres commerciaux d'île
de france l'ancien footballeur pour
encore mesurer sa popularité
on continue à parler du paris saint
germain le projet est attendu par les
supporters du psg depuis de nombreuses
années et il va rythmer 2020 le futur
centre d'entraînement va enfin voir le
jour
le site avec tous ses équipements
dernière génération sera construit sur
la commune de poissy la présentation a
été faite cette semaine davantage de jus
laughren ville c'était l'un des moments
phare du salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise le paris saint germain a
présenté ce mercredi 11 décembre son
futur centre d'entraînement
le site sera implanté sur le nord de la
commune de poitiers à 25 minutes du parc
des princes d'abord c'est un projet qui
valorise le territoire avant de
valoriser la seule ville de poissy à
voir le paris saint germain sur 75
hectares avec 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux
nos millions d'euros de taxes annuelles
pour la communauté urbaine
oui c'est juste tire juste exceptionnel
faut bien comprendre que une marque
comme le psg
savoir quelle est la implanté dans les
yvelines pour un retentissement
international
c'est une publicité à zéro euro
donc c'est fait quelque chose de
formidable le site est encore un terrain
vague mais les fouilles archéologiques
ont débuté les premiers travaux seront
invisibles au printemps à terme le
centre comprendra les équipements
ultramodernes avec un dojo un terrain de
handball un stade de 5000 places et 17
terrains de football dont un couvert
on n'a pas forcément cette ambition on
va tâcher d'être dans les meilleurs
c'est notre volonté d'être dans les
meilleurs donc on a un travail qu'on a
réalisé en toute humilité il ya encore
des très grands clubs qui sont présents
ont fait partie des très grands clubs on
va tâcher d'être le meilleur
la livraison définitive est à l'heure
actuelle programmée pour l'été 2022 le
coût total des travaux devrait avoisiner
les 220 millions d'euros
cap à présent sur villes pro un stage de
kung fu s'est déroulée ce dimanche à
l'espace michel petrucciani
le court était donnée pas réagi cela qu
elle il vit à taïwan qui s'est déplacé
spécialement pour enseigner le kung fu
traditionnel 50 participants étaient
présents ce stage au tarif libre était
organisée pour aider les réfugiés
tibétains qui ont séjourné dans la
commune pendant une semaine en décembre
les recettes perçues lors de ce stage
iront intégralement à l'association acr
pour ofi des réfugiés tibétains réaction
au micro de manon varaldo on connaît
bien la cause des tibétains
et on était particulièrement sensible à
leur venue et
on a voulu faire un moment de partage
avec eux malgré qu'ils sont partis jeudi
dernier à mantes la ville
on va maintenant passer à notre top 3
des sportifs qui ont marqué l'année à
2019 dans les ivy nous recevons andy
cabreira avila sur ce plateau cette
année east qui est maître nageur à la
piscine de saint cyr l'école a enchaîné
cette année à des records et des
compétitions bonsoir andy cabreira
bonjour migraine alors est ce que cette
année vous avez le sentiment que c'était
votre année c'est difficile à dire parce
que chaque année à des projets de
nouveaux projets oui je pense que chaque
année à ces beaux projets à faire alors
vous avez par exemple respirer moins de
cinq minutes en six heures pour dénoncer
la condition des animaux en captivité
tout à fait d'un projet qui s'appellent
norah la captivité
oui en liberté l'objectif du projet
c'est sensibiliser les enfants n'est pas
une cité les parcs aquatiques et dévoile
les dauphins les mammifères marins en
captivité mais plutôt allé le voir en
liberté parce que c'est vraiment de
l'esclavagé qu'est ce qu'on voit un pas
critique donc j'essaie de ces sionistes
les enfants ont maintenant mois dans la
peau de nos francs ces belles qui coule
au fond qu elle refuse de se nourrir
pour pouvoir défendre sa liberté etc les
enfants qui ont été dans la cage pour me
libérer et c'est donc l'objectif c'était
respirer les mois possibles en six
heures et à respirer
quatre minutes et 12 secondes sur six
heures voilà c'est une façon de dénoncer
c'était d'esclaves hd nous laissions et
la souffrance qu'on inflige aux
mammifères marins voilà le message était
là et comment on fait pour respirer que
que 4 minutes et 12 secondes c'est ça
oui comment c'est possible
alors c'est un accord inédit parce que
personne jamais a fait ça est simplement
s'entraîner de façon spécifique à
pouvoir donner son souffle et prend les
minimes d'un spi des fois les tendances
prix était inférieur à une seconde 47
centièmes il ya quatre kilomètres heure
qui comme nous met les moments que la
bouche la vocation deylaud et lanta
l'eau voilà pendant six heures c'est
long mais
c'est fiable qu'on a la conviction pour
une belle cause en fer et les conditions
que les faits il était enfermé dans une
cage avec des chaînes et les rangs des
dauphins avec une monopalme et simuler
la détresse d'un enfant en captivité
dieu dira merci à toutes les personnes
qui ont participé les bénévoles dagois
mundo l'association s'est tassée
greenpeace c'est super l'enjeu 281 et
brigitte bardot et deux associations
tous les bénévoles et la cae
on a fait un beau projet ces projets
j'ai déjà d'abord la présenter dans tous
les secteurs excepté ceci dit ma
démission dauphin pourpalers enfants de
la captivité et tous les enfants ont été
sensibilisés à cette cause est-ce que
l'on peut le faire votre record avec de
l'entraînement à oui on peut faire
beaucoup mieux c'est celui-là et je fais
d avoir la motivation pour les faire oui
alors vous êtes également partie sur les
championnats du monde qui était à
villefranche sur mer
oui pourquoi avoir voulu tester cette
année en profondeur cette fois ci ils
ont constaté qu'y je découvre là la même
profondeur depuis subi à cuba a cherché
ensuite en france c'est plus difficile
parce que la mer les loin donc les jeux
je fais plutôt d'amener en piscine mais
ma passion c'est comment la grande bleue
aller en profondeur donc cette année
pour la première fois cuba a été
représentée par moi même et encore
légalement copain à moi qui s'appelle
jordan et pour la première fois qu a été
représenté dans son champion du monde
d'aller en profondeur donc cette année
je suis descendu à 51 m on a mené en
profondeur pour moi c'est un vrai que
personnel c'est très loin à des
champions mais c'est cette c'est beau à
faire c'est magnifique que j'étais très
fier très fier des procédés mon pays et
l'association aqua mundo
quand il faisait ricains et ses
compétitions alors c'était une
compétition inédite pour vous est ce que
vous voudrez le refaire l'année
prochaine oui là en ce type en 2020 et
de participer à une compétition
internationale d'amener en profondeur au
même endroit et après par la suite aux
champions de france d'amener en
profondeur toujours la présenter à cuba
mon pays natal dans ces deux domaines
dans la menée en profondeur et des
records également sont au programme en
2003 par l année prochaine pour la
journée modèles géants les buts de
rassembler beaucoup d'enfants autour
d'une belle cause pour préserver la
planète surtout connaître contre les
plastiques et pour la planète toujours
merci
andy caméra il a dépassé
le bâton vous suivra et 14 attention en
2020 et j'espère de nouveaux records on
continue notre top 3 de la saison
sportive 2010 9 on retrouve un pistard
quentin lafargue le sportif licencié au
vélo club est long pour 50 ans olivier a
remporté trois titres majeurs cette
saison
des performances qui devrait l'emmener
aux jeux olympiques nous lui avons posé
trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le cyclisme sur piste
quand j'étais jeune
justement pour me perfectionner en
cyclisme globalement et j'ai très vite
adhéré
adoré car toutes les disciplines qui
sont mis en lien avec le sprint donc la
vitesse est assez vite le keirin et
j'aime beaucoup les épreuves par équipes
aussi sur la tête
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir en carrière je
pense que ça reste et il ya des chances
que ça ça reste ça touchant macaire
c'est la première médaille que j'ai
obtenus lors des championnats du monde
élite c'était ici en 2015 devant un
vélodrome rempli
en plus de ça c'était le dernier sprint
du championnat puisque
on a couru une belle non c'est à dire
qu'il y avait 1 1 avec mon compte pour
mon adversaire et c'était vraiment le
dernier sprint du championnat après mois
ont ils ont éteint les lumières presque
donc vraies belles images m'ont alors
j'en retiens énormément d'émotion
les objectifs pour la saison qui vient
évidemment les jeux olympiques
en ligne de mire qui seront en août
prochain avant ça il y aura une manche
de coupe du monde début janvier
aussi les championnats du monde en
en fin février début mars sur lesquels
j'aurai à coeur de bain bien figurez
vous que j'ai un maillot de champion du
monde à défendre on a une médaille d'or
en vitesse par équipes à défendre aussi
donc le faire aussi être très performant
sur l'épreuve du keirin
on termine par notre dernier top là
plaisir oiseaux julie un peugeot 30 ans
rapporté cet été le concours de miss
sirène france et oui vous avez bien
entendu ces disciplines inédite et
originale mélange à la fois le sport et
la beauté objectif retenir sa
respiration avec un costume de sirène
elle a remporté cette épreuve face à
huit candidates et c'est un vrai sport
au sport car elle s'entraîne plusieurs
fois par semaine à la piscine à des
clayes-sous-bois je vous propose
maintenance de revivre tous les moments
forts qui ont rythmé le paysage sportif
évinois à cette année de la coupe du
monde de football féminin à l'open de
france de golf en passant par les
championnats de france de gymnastique
les yvelines on était à terre de sport
regardez je transmets pas ma flot d je
revis a ses limites mais technique
j'ai connu se déplacer
[Musique]
c'était très plaisant de gagner
aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le maillot
jaune ce sera sympa de le porter ce
maillot jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était
une étape très dure avec beaucoup de
vent mais l'équipe a fait du très bon
travail avec est six coureurs dans le
premier groupe coté
j'ai pas au gal capacité pulmonaire
ok tu joues à cames à force de volonté
[Musique]
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour en créer
un nouveau
et après on est sur des manipulations de
balles sur du dodge ball en année
américain on est sûrs d'eux mêmes
manipulations du ballon de volée
[Musique]
oui super cette première place qu'on
occupe et on est trois quarts de l'année
ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite
en revient aux joueurs au staff aux
équipements 1 qui m'accompagne la
direction qui m'a fait confiance cette
année est vraiment fier aussi de
terminer meilleure défense de la ligue
de paris
[Musique]
ben jawad
seeger
enfin
impressionnant tous les tons qu'ils font
ça me donne des idées
[Musique]
la compétition approche plus plus
agrandi pour iliad effervescence donc
c'est bien pour nous c'est positif pour
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc on en prend c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est toujours valorisant d'être sur un
terrain de faire partager ce que c'est
ce qui nous a permis de gagner pas mal
de titres
[Musique]
les publics français était la criée
encore et encore et je me suis dit il
faut que j'aille pop geste et j'ai
poussé dans les bosses s'est passé c'est
juste incroyable d'avoir gagné ici
[Musique]
je suis enfin sorti du salar de uyuni
j'ai rejoint la terre les cailloux
portion du sel j'en avais marre d'avoir
les fesses toutes blanches à cause de ça
donc voilà c'est la fin de cette
aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude dr
[Musique]
on
c'est que du bonheur c'est
l'aboutissement de huit mois de travail
pour eux mais l'équipe aille sont
naturellement et bien une centaine une
bonne centaine de bénévoles mais
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée
rambouillet tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs
[Musique]
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'y étais allé en plus tôt en
mode
plutôt défi personnel
voulait vivre aussi une expérience avec
d'autres sirènes parce que c'est pas
tous les jours que l'on peut rencontrer
des sirènes en france
[Musique]
c'est très très rare de les avoir c'est
vrai en france le voyage déjà un fou qui
se déplace et on les a déjà eu deux
trois ans et c'est vrai que c'est très
rare qui viennent et c'est vraiment
exceptionnel de les avoir en français
[Musique]
on
je pense que mon niveau même toute la
semaine était très très bon
je savais que je trouvais bien joué ici
parce que j'avais dit je l'avais déjà
fait l'année passée j'avais gagné ici
aussi donc je me sentais bien je me sens
très confiant
[Musique]
c'est le métier car c'est une des
courses une des 4 5 pour me dis qu'en
france et puis on est du coin de
versailles
on court en pleine campagne mais c'est
pas un trade c'est difficile mais à
l'arrivée on est toujours satisfait
[Musique]
on l'a
c'est énormément de joie voilà ça fait
ça fait 18 ans que je suis pro j'ai
gagné deux fois j'aurais dû gagner plus
souvent comme je l'aï déjà dit souvent
le fait de gagner chez vous c'est génial
j'ai joué un peu l'impression de faire
partie du paysage golfique français
[Musique]
ça me plaît parce que voilà j'ai des
anecdotes aussi dans mon passé qui m'ont
permis de rencontrer des champions je
m'en souviens ça m'a marqué je m'en suis
servi avant de parler sabre laser et que
marylène ya pichot qui nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau ce sera dans un instant
coup de projecteur maintenant sur une
structure qui devrait marquer l'année à
2020 le club des scripts de trappes
le club qui compte 80 licenciés
notamment ayoub ferjani maître d'armes
et tireurs à de nombreux objectifs pour
l'année prochaine nous recevons sur ce
plateau il ya ferjani alexis des jo
ce tireur au club et également à
nathalie haruf présidente du club
bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter l'histoire de ce
club l'un des serres de ce club parce
que le club va fêter ses 50 ans cette
année en 2020 donc c'est une association
qui depuis de nombreuses années à un
très bon niveau au niveau du fleuret et
période c'est pour ça qu'on a notre
activité sur une grande partie du
département
et puis cette année on a décidé d'ouvrir
un peu plus le loisir avec l'ouverture
de créneaux débutant à elancourt et puis
du sabre laser sur élan corp également
donc je vous disais 80 licenciés environ
après voilà un chiffre qui est stable
dans le désert progression on était un
peu moins de 70 l'année dernière donc
mais c'est toujours à peu près les mêmes
à peu près les mêmes chiffres puisque ça
permet d'avoir des anciens
l'enseignement et en encadrement de
qualité alors ayew ferjani vous êtes le
maître d'armes mais désaxé structure
qu'est ce que voulait inculquer à ce
club
deux choses déjà je veux toujours
partagée d'un patient qui est de donner
vos d'essayer de ramener les tireurs le
plus haut possible pour faire des
résultats pour progresser et on a
toujours la partie loisirs on n'est pas
fixé que compétition compétent il ya
toujours la moitié des terreurs qui est
mais des tireurs qui viennent le soir
parce que c'est comme une famille on
vient tirer
viola qui viennent aussi pour pour
s'amuser c'est une histoire y en a qui
ont fait des scream tout jeunes qui
reprennent là vingt ans après ils ont
fait une expérience professionnelle à
droite à gauche qui viennent et ça reste
toujours bien pour nous pour nos jeunes
qui sont en train de monter qui essaye
de progresser pour faire des résultats
au niveau national
donc c'est des sparring partner idéal
alexis comment il est comme coach
comment il est est-ce qui vous aident à
progresser
oui depuis qu'il est là au club de
trappes dû beaucoup progressé j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses et c'est sûr de
l'avoir à nos côtés avec son expérience
ça va être forcément
alors vous avez participé aux jo de rio
notamment exactement vous essayer de
transmettre un petit peu cette
expérience tous les jours c'est mon
objectif
j'essaye de transmettre de ce nom on
essaie même content je fais des séances
d'assaut avec eux on essaie de se mettre
en mode quand pète de laisser personne
de gagner de les motiver après on fait
toujours une analyse après le combat
pourquoi tu as perdu pourquoi ça s'est
passé comme ça quel style de jeu il faut
mettre en place quand est-ce qu'il faut
varier son jeu on est un sport de combat
donc dès que tu relâches un peu tu peux
te prendre 4 5 touches de suite
donc on essaie de toujours travailler
sur ces petits moments tu es tu déçu
pour qu'ils progressent parce qu'on
complète c'est différent ça passe vite
donc comme tu peux dès que peut gagner
au bout de 20 secondes comme tu peux
lâcher par deux matches marylène
iapichino alors vous connaissez bien le
club des scream de trappes un car vous y
avez découvert leur nouvelle discipline
on en parlait justement lance en
septembre le sabre laser
oui michael il ya bien longtemps et aux
états unis la pratique a commencé un
long voyage jusqu'en france cette
discipline à effectuer car septembre
elle s'est installée officiellement
devenue la quatrième la 4e armes de
l'escrim le sabre laser et qui a reconnu
par la fédération française d'escrimé
il est toujours en mouvement et l'avenir
de ce sport et même des compétitions
entre apprentis y mettre l'existant on
s'est rapprochés assez rapidement fait
de la fédération qui avait les mêmes
objectifs que nous c'est-à-dire
sécuriser la pratique et faire en sorte
qu'il ya un vrai programme de mise en
place au niveau des animateurs des
éducateurs pour que les gens qui
encadrent le sabre laser le fassent de
manière correcte et au respect des lois
françaises au niveau du score alors vous
allez parler comme maître yoda pendant
toute la chronique marylène michael vous
rassurer je me dois car je ne suis
qu'une padawan les sabres laser c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle ont plusieurs
manières de pratiquer cet art martial
pour les grands fans de l'univers star
wars il ya la façon chorégraphié comme
vous le voyez sur ces images c'était un
combat en équipe lors d'un championnat
organisé par l'académie de sabre laser
de voisins-le-bretonneux pour les
sportifs il ya le combat à la touche
avec les règles établies de la ffe ici
aussi des compétitions officielles sont
organisés un point pour les mains et le
pommeau trois points pour les membres 5
points pour la tête et le torse pour les
bases guillaume et du club de trappes
m'a tout expliqué pendant leurs
entraînements où ils sont accueillis
dans un gymnase des longs cours
alors guillaume houët instructeur ici au
club de sabre laser vous allez me
montrer un peu quels sont les gestes
principaux alors en fait dans notre
système de combat on a ce qu'on appelle
un système d'armé c'est à dire que pour
qu'une touche soit valide il faut que
préalablement le combattant est amené
salam derrière lui donc c'est plus
visuel pour le public et ça permet un
arbitrage était beaucoup plus facile
donc autres ça en jeu par deux affaires
ça permet d'être beaucoup plus
facilement arbitrable donc la deuxième
chose c'est le début d'une phrase armes
phrase armes c'est un échange complet
jusqu'à ce qu'une séparation d'une autre
matin ce qu'on fait ce qu'on appelle un
arm et d'engagement on se dira que la
lame le komo et la main doivent passer
derrière
voilà donc au si on est éloigné l'un de
l'autre la première frappe passe
derrière
et une fois qu'on a commencé à faire des
échanges il ya juste besoin de faire ça
d'accord
l'autre chose c'est ce qu'on appelle une
seconde parade riposte on est on a une
notion de priorité chez nous dire que le
premier qui va faire son arme et
d'engagement l'autre n'a pas droit de
l'attaqué ok donc ils obligés de se
mettre en défense à partir du moment où
je viens vous attaquez vous paraît c'est
vous qui prenez la priorité moi j'ai pas
le droit de vous attaquer quatre fois de
suite comme un bourrin donc à partir moi
je suis bloqué s'avoue d'attaqué je vous
bloque etc etc etc
s'il me sur un peu comme au ping pong
c'est une motion de renvoi très bien je
pense que compris on va s'équiper on va
essayer c'est parti alors seigneur sith
ou maître jedi
c'est michael on pourra essayer le sabre
laser j'en ai choisi un bleu bien sûr je
vous laisse voir mon combat jeu
compliqué nature
[Musique]
pensé pour moi c'est assez sportif le
sabre laser à elancourt c'est une fois
par semaine donc si vous les tc vous
pouvez juste vous renseigner auprès du
club et que la force soit avec vous
merci marc il aime c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
passer d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année
[Musique]